TIME TONIGHT.
>> THANK YOU.
♪ ♪
>> Bret: NEW FOX POLLS
INDICATE JOE BIDEN LEADS
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND THREE MAJOR
BATTLEGROUND STATES.
WISCONSIN, THEY PREFERRED THE
DEMOCRAT BY NINE PERCENTAGE
POINTS.
THE MARGIN HAS FOUR END ARIZONA,
TWO IN OHIO.
TONIGHT, REPUBLICANS ARE NOW
SEEKING A NEW HOME FOR THIS
SUMMER’S NOMINATING CONVENTION
FOR REAL.
NOT JUST TALKING ABOUT IT.
HERE’S CORRESPONDED TO DUCEY.
>> IN ALL THREE SWING STATES
WHERE BIDEN LEADS TRUMP, THEY
HAVE SOMETHING IN COMMON.
THE EXACT SAME PERCENTAGE.
IT’S IMPORTANT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP TO SET AN
EXAMPLE AND WEAR A MASK IN
PUBLIC.
AND IN ALL THREE STATES, BY THE
MEETS WITH VOTERS WHO SAY THEY
ARE EXTREMELY MOTIVATED TO VOTE
IN THE ELECTION.
THIS COMES AS ANOTHER SWING
STATES, NORTH CAROLINA, IS
LOSING A CONVENTION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP TWEETS "STILL AN
SHELTER IN PLACE MODE AND NOT
ALLOWING US TO OCCUPY THE ARENA
AS ORIGINALLY ANTICIPATED AND
PROMISED.
WHAT HAVE SHOWCASED NORTH
CAROLINA TO THE WORLD AND BRING
DEAD AND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS FOR
THE STAGE.
WE ARE NOW FORCED TO SEEK
ANOTHER STATE TO HOST THE 2020
REPUBLICAN NATIONAL CONVENTION."
>> SOME BEEN CONSIDERED,
FLORIDA, GEORGIA, TENNESSEE, AND
NEVADA.
ONE OF THEM GETS THE
HIGH-PROFILE OF EVENTS LIKE THE
PRESIDENT ACCEPTING THE
NOMINATION.
CHARLETTE JUST KEEPS THE
CONVENTION’S OFFICIAL BUSINESS
MEETINGS AND REPUBLICANS HERE
SAY SAY THAT’S DEVASTATING.
>> ESPECIALLY FOR THOSE FOLKS
THAT ARE EMPLOYED IN THE
HOSPITALITY INDUSTRY WHO HAVE
BEEN SHUT DOWN AND SHUT OUT OF
WORK.
>> THEY CALLED US A GOOD
DISTRACTION.
IF THEY HAVE THE PEOPLE OF
NORTH KOREANORTHCAROLINA.
>> JOE BIDEN IS TRYING TO LEAD
THE WAY ON REFORMING POLICE
TACTICS LIKE WHERE TO SHOOT THE
SUSPECTS.
>> INSTEAD OF STANDING THERE AND
TEACHING A COP TO SHOOT THEM IN
THE LEG, YOU SHOULD THEM IN THE
HEART.
THERE IS A VERY DIFFERENT THING.
>> REPUBLICANS CALL THAT A
RESPONSIBLE BEARD >> NEXT THING
YOU KNOW, SOMEBODY WILL SUGGEST
WILD, JUST SHOOT THE WEAPON OUT
OF THEIR HAND.
THAT ONLY HAPPENS IN THE MOVIES.
>> ONE OF THE GROUPS UP FOR
GRABS IN THE NEW FOX POLL
TONIGHT, SUBURBAN WHITE VOTERS.
IN WISCONSIN, THEY LIKE BIDEN.
IN OHIO, THEY ARE SPLIT.
A LOT CAN HAPPEN BETWEEN NOW AND
THE ELECTION PERIOD OF FIVE